- Hey guys, this is
May from team Gary Vee.
I'm Gary's international
strategist and community manager.
Today, I'll be working with Jim
to explain the content model
through this 4Ds.
- This portion is like
with me, so I think this is
when you need to get
selfish, like you need
to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing, firing is knowing.
Like, you gotta go fast,
that's how you get shit done,
that's how you figure stuff out.
This is the television, and
the television is the radio.
It's the 4Ds, motherfuckers.
- So what we're gonna do now
is walk through six different
moments that we pulled
out from this episode,
and we're gonna explain to
you like why we picked them,
why we didn't pick them,
how we reimagined them
for each platform, and what
the impact of those were
at the end of this episode.
- I value the trenches, and
people value the ivory towers,
and that is why nobody scares me.
- So before we go into
explaining how we use
the content model, I
actually want to explain
what the content model
is, so the content model
is actually a pillar piece of
content that we use to break
into individual smaller pieces of content.
We use the pillar content
to reuse, reshape, reformat,
so we can fit it into different platforms.
Now, the content model
itself is actually available
to everyone right now.
It's a free 86 page deck that is available
on garyvee.com/contentmodel.
(dinging)
So now we're gonna dive into
how we use the content model
and how you can use it as well.
So for this clip, we actually
had four titles that we,
meaning Gary and the team, came up with.
When we presented it on
Twitter, we actually showed
a raw clip with subtitles on it.
Over 50% of the audience
don't listen with sound on,
so this is the first way
that we engage the audience.
Second, we actually use
the poll options on Twitter
which have a 25 character
limit and we presented
the four titles in a sequence
and then we let the community
choose which title they like best.
By engaging our audience, we're able
to create a ripple effect
among our community.
One, they get to participate
in creating content for Gary,
so that hypes them up.
Two, we give them early
exposure to the piece of content
so when the full thing comes
out, which is the full pillar
content, people will feel
more excited and more familiar
with that piece of content, and
three, it helps our audience
feel special because this is
actually an exclusive piece
of content that we haven't
shown to anyone else.
- We're always looking for
strong, actionable messages,
and in this one there's
a little bit of a twist,
so when Gary says hey,
the entire company's out
at six o'clock, we think our
users are gonna find that kind
of interesting given Gary's work ethic
which is so legendary.
The second part about this
is that we framed this clip
to appeal to two different audiences.
One being the employer that's
doing the hiring and firing,
but the second is from
the employee who's often
misunderstood as someone who
doesn't work hard enough.
When Gary stands up for the
employee, we found that that's
been very well responded to.
- I grew up in the alcohol, I
owned weedlibrary.com in 1997.
- So in this clip, Gary
actually talks about owning
weedlibrary.com in 1997.
- I've been on cannabis, but
I'm not a cannabis expert.
I'm patient and thoughtful
and pay attention.
I don't need to brand
myself as an expert or like,
you know how many people
literally that we all know
on Twitter or other things
have, in the last fours years
been a social media expert,
a blockchain expert,
and a cannabis expert?
And there's nothing
wrong with chasing news.
I mean, there's a lot of
quick money to be made
and I don't judge, it's just
not what I'm interested in,
and so timing matters to
me, and so for example,
if we're gonna go practical on
the blockchain conversation,
we got a long way to go.
- So we ended up not using
this clip because Gary jumped
from this topic that we wanted
to use into a different topic
and that in turn helped
us realize like oh,
he didn't finish his thought
process and we didn't want
to just put this out and
not provide enough value
to our audience.
- So Gary often tackles topics
that others shy away from,
so when he does that we like
to take that opportunity
to answer a really important
question that people
are often afraid to ask.
When we build Instagram clips,
we do it in a very specific way.
There's four things we try
to include with almost every
video, the first being a
hook, and that's a three
to five second video clip
that we move to the front
of the video to capture people's attention
as they're scrolling through the feed.
Next, we include the sonic branding tag.
This is something that
we include on every clip,
it's a mandatory requirement
because Gary's very high
on the future of voice,
and this is how we're gonna
establish our branding on all the videos
that we have out there.
Next, we craft a title that
provides actionable advice.
That's something that we've
seen our audience responds
really well to when Gary
provides motivational,
actionable guidance and
instruction on how to do something.
Our call to actions are really important
because it is the closure of
that video and we really hope
that users after watching
this video will take action.
It's the core to every message
that Gary has is to do,
so we try to close with
some specific direction
as to what you should be
thinking about or doing next.
- I would be a top five sportscaster
in our society right now if I started.
I know a lot about sports,
and I know how the framework works.
I'd be bigger than Stephen
A. Smith, I promise you.
- As you can see, it's
actually a TikTok clip.
Gary's been super bullish
about TikTok and we want
to make sure we're moving
forward any clip that we ingest
that we actually think about the platform.
What we did was actually go into TikTok
and find a trending song
that could match this moment.
Once we found that song, we
actually did our own version
and our own editing of that
song in Adobe Premiere.
Once we finished the whole
packaging of that clip,
we exported it into TikTok and
actually chose the same song
in TikTok but muted it so the
algorithm on TikTok would know
that hey, we used this song,
but we actually just had
our own version on top of it.
- In this clip, Gary gives
very tactical advice,
so when he does that we really
like to take advantage of it
and build it out in extensive ways.
In this case, we built three
different pieces of content,
one being a cartoon that
we published to LinkedIn
that summed up the concept in
a really short, punchy way,
the second being an Instagram
clip which we assigned
as a heavy hitter for the day,
and so a heavy hitter clip
is one that we will take the
whole day to produce and build
because we want to give
it special attention
and be really thoughtful and strategic
about how we roll it out.
The third is that we built
a slide deck that takes
this concept that we summarized
in a cartoon on LinkedIn
and built it out extensively
for LinkedIn, so know people
can pore over this tactical
advice step-by-step
and capture all the nuances
of what Gary's suggesting.
(upbeat music)
Now, we only showed you a
few examples of the micros
that we created from
this hour-long meeting,
but let's take a look at the total impact
this whole library of content had.
- Hey everyone, we knew
that was a lot to digest
and it probably seems
overwhelming right now,
but although you may be
thinking that, how can I do this
without a team Gary, if
you really think about it,
Gary actually started
doing this all by himself
for 10 plus years before
he got a team Gary,
so really what we want to
do is empower you to know
that just start with one
pillar piece of content
and one micro and just
get going and just test
and see what you like
and what works for you.
Wish you guys the best.
(beeping)
- Okay, Gary has, ugh, started
off so well, all right.
Gary asked us to create a special, ugh.
(beeping)
- [Cameraman] Action.
- Hey guys, I know that
may seem overwhelming,
everything that we just talked about,
but we really don't want
you to feel that way.
You might be thinking, how do I do this
without a team Gary Bee?
Team Gary Bee!
(laughing)
Team Gary Bee, I'm sorry.